[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis einen schönen guten
abend an diesem pfingstwochenende das
wichtigste vom sportkreis stresow für
sich sehr gerne genannt jetzt aber
erstmal die wichtigsten nachrichten und
da schauen wir als erstes auf den
bergungseinsatz in oberbayern
nach dem zugunglück in garmisch finden
helfer unter den trümmern ein fünftes
todesopfer in unfall erklären können sie
sich noch nicht
herum spritpreise trotz gesenkter
steuern werden benzin und diesel wieder
teurer manche politiker wollen
ölkonzerne jetzt stärker zur kasse
bitten
und sieg mit ausrufezeichen in die erste
der weltrangliste der iga schirm tag
steht im finale von paris gegen coco
golf ihre extraklasse unter beweis
es ist eines der schwersten zugunglücke
der vergangenen jahre in garmisch
partenkirchen sind noch immer die
helferinnen und helfer im einsatz
bisher wurden fünf menschen tot geborgen
mehr als 40 menschen wurden verletzt als
der regionalzug entgleist wir sprechen
gleich mit unserer korrespondentin vor
ort über mögliche unglücksursachen
zuerst aber jemand pfanzelt über den
bergungseinsatz
gegen 13 uhr werden sichtschutzwände
aufgebaut mit zwei kränen heben die
einsatzkräfte einen der umgefallenen
waggons an unter den 50 tonnen schweren
weg finden sie ein weiteres todesopfer
derzeit gehen wir aber nicht von
weiteren opfern aus abschließend kann
ich zum jetzigen zeitpunkt nicht
beantworten bei den toten handelt es
sich um vier frauen und eine männliche
person mehrere menschen werden noch
vermisst
ein stich ins herz so nennt es heute der
bayerische ministerpräsident
man muss sich das so vorstellen
das ist kurz vor den ferien im zug
ausgelassene stimmung in einer der
schönsten regionen die bayern er hat und
dann passiert sowas und verändert
möglicherweise sein leben komplett und
deswegen ist es immer ein schock die
bergungsarbeiten gestalten sich
schwierig die waggons sind so schwer das
spezialgerät herangeschafft werden muss
manche einsatzkräfte sind mehr als 24
stunden vor ort im einsatz funktioniert
man einfach man muss funktionieren
danach setzen wir uns alle zusammen
reden wir mal über das erlebte wir
schauen dass es in jedem gut geht und
dass sie emotional gesänge familien oder
nach hause zurückkehrt warum ist der zug
entgleist warum sind die mittleren
waggons umgekippt diese fragen
beschäftigen nun die kriminalpolizei
und an der unglücksstelle ist unsere
reporterin jutta sonne wald jutta noch
laufen die ermittlungen wir haben es
gerade gehört aber was wird denn stand
jetzt als wahrscheinlichste
unglücksursache gesehen
also noch gibt es wie gesagt nichts
neues zu der unglücksursache keine
neuigkeiten aber auszuschließen ist
bisher nach wie vor dass es eine
kollision mit einem anderen zug gab als
wahrscheinlichste ursache gehen experten
davon aus dass es ein technischer defekt
sein könnte entweder am gleis oder am
zug da ja auch nur die drei mittleren
waggons entgleist sind und nicht das
hintere teil des zuges der antriebs
wagen oder auch nicht die lok vorne wäre
der zug über ein größeres hindernis
gefahren dann ist wahrscheinlich die
wahrscheinlichkeit größer gewesen dass
eben vorne auch die lok betroffen wäre
aber das ist nur eine theorie die hier
aufgestellt worden ist im moment laufen
die ermittlungen noch in alle richtungen
dafür hat die kripo hier auch eine
eigene sonderkommission eingerichtet die
soko zug die auch von bahnexperten
unterstützt wird und die analyse wie und
warum es zu diesem unglück kommen konnte
kann vielleicht noch wochen oder auch
monate dauern heißt es hier vor ort aus
garmisch oder sonne wald dankeschön
blicken wir auf den ukraine krieg
frankreichs präsident marco warnt wir
dürfen russland nicht demütigen demnach
hatte mit nach dem ende der kämpfe eine
diplomatische lösung gefunden werden
kann frankreich sieht sich als
vermittler vom ukrainischen präsidenten
berater kommt jetzt die einschätzung
dass sich der krieg noch zwei bis sechs
monate hinziehen könne im donbass
erhöhte russland offenbar militärisch
den druck antoine kurzem berichtet
russische kampfhubschrauber feuern auf
ziele in der ukraine offenbar
intensiviert die luftwaffe ihre angriffe
im donbass weil die offensive am boden
nur langsam vorankommt nach einschätzung
des britischen
militärgeheimdienstes kommt dabei nicht
nur präzisionsmunition zum einsatz die
folge zerstörte wohngebiete wie hier in
slovan im osten der ukraine
die russische armee ist rücksichtslos
sie versucht nicht nur so viele menschen
wie möglich zu töten sondern will auch
die gesamte infrastruktur zerstören die
zum leben notwendig ist
in der schwer umkämpften stadt hier wir
ordoñez sprenge die russische armee
gezielt brücken um die ukrainischen
truppen vom nachschub abzuschneiden
moskau meldet wie gewohnt militärische
erfolge dabei sei auch ein schlag gegen
den westen gelungen
[Applaus]
mit hochpräzisen luft boden raketen
wurde eine artillerieschule angegriffen
dort wurden ukrainische soldaten
ausgebildet an waffen aus dem westen von
ausbildern aus dem ausland sagt der
sprecher des
verteidigungsministeriums und ergänzt
die russische luftabwehr habe in der
region odessa ein transportflugzeug mit
waffen und munition an bord abgeschossen
ob es sich dabei auch um westliche
waffensysteme handelt blieb unklar
seit putins überfall auf die ukraine
zeigt die nato mehr präsenz an der
ostflanke am boden aber auch in der luft
aufklärer und kampfjets in unterwegs
etwa über dem baltikum polen oder
rumänien und das zu wirklich jeder zeit
auch als abschreckung aber kein einsatz
ohne kerosin und getankt wird in der
luft von wunstorf in niedersachsen aus
starten solche a400m der luftwaffe quasi
als fliegende tankstelle unser reporter
an seinem stern hat jetzt exklusiv eine
mission dabei begleitet
f 18 kampfjets und eurofighter auf
patrouille an der natur ostflanke
luftraum überwachen auch an der grenze
zum kriegsgebiet
den treibstoff für die mission liefert
vor allem die luftwaffe in der luft wir
sind unterwegs im a400m der ist fast
täglich im einsatz seit putins angriff
auf die ukraine
ihr beitrag zur erhöhung der präsenz die
ich sehr wichtig ist um die
reaktionsfähigkeit und
abschreckungsfähigkeit der allianz zu
erhöhen sagt der kommandant der tag für
ihn und seine kameraden beginnt früh um
5 uhr 30 staaten die vorbereitungen in
wunstorf niedersachsen pünktlich um 8
uhr tecco ziel heute ostpolen nach
eineinhalb stunden flug der erste
kontakt zwei deutsche eurofighter
brauchen treibstoff ist beginnt der
heikelste teil der einsätze kerosin
wechselt den besitzer bei tempo 700 und
8000 meter über der erde
wir haben aus den kameras dabei können
wir den gesamten tankvorgang beobachten
und haben somit die möglichkeit jeden
einzelnen schritt des betankung vorgangs
zu überprüfen die betankung missionen
der luftwaffe sind extrem wichtig denn
seit putins blutigen überfall auf die
ukraine hat die nato mehr als 30
flugzeuge an der ostflanke in der luft
und das permanent tag und nacht
insgesamt sechs kampfjets versorgt die
luftwaffe heute dann geht's nach hause
da wird direkt frisch aufgetankt für den
nächsten einsatz an der ostgrenze der
nato
jetzt ein thema das viele autofahrer
innen umtreibt die regierung hat ja
versprochen das benzin und diesel
spürbar billiger werden seit mittwoch
gilt daher ein tank rabatt aber die
preise steigen vielerorts bereits wieder
kritik daher an den mineralölkonzernen
die zurzeit besonders hohe
milliardengewinne machen aus der politik
mehren sich nun die stimmen
krisengewinner zusätzlich zu besteuern
karl hinterleitner
tag für tag verursacht der krieg in der
ukraine leid und fordert menschenleben
er sorgt aber auch für aufrüstung und
steigende energiepreise bei denen die
verbraucher verlieren aber andere
gewinnen das könne man nicht hinnehmen
meint spd chef lars klingbeil
es kann nicht sein dass sich die
mineralölkonzerne in der krise die
tasche noch voller machen vertreter der
grünen stimmen zu die abschöpfung von
zusatzgewinnen sei nötig eine sogenannte
über gewinn steuer sinnvoll die märkte
sind offensichtlich gestört in dem
bereich und insofern ist es nur richtig
dass geprüft wird wie an der stelle im
sinne einer sozial ökologischen
marktwirtschaft eingegriffen werden kann
das kann zum beispiel passieren durch
eine über gewinn steuer die linke sieht
eine extra abgabe als soziales gebot
das modell was wir als linke
vorgeschlagen haben ist die gewinne vor
und nach der krise um während der krise
miteinander zu vergleichen wenn zum
beispiel die gewinne explodiert sind zum
beispiel zehn millionen mehr als im
vorjahr dann müsste auf diesen über
gewinn eine steuer von 25 prozent
entrichtet werden die fdp steht einer
über gewinn steuer kritisch gegenüber
und chris demokraten wittern schon
streit in der ampel zunächst einmal
würde es mich interessieren ob eine
solche über gewinn steuerte ein
vorschlag der koalition ist denn die fdp
scheint ja dagegen zu sein während grüne
und spd sie propagieren insofern wäre
zunächst einmal eine klärung der
position in der regierung notwendig
wirtschaftsexperten waren eine
extrasteuer sei denkbar dürfe aber nicht
die falschen treffen man muss sehr
vorsichtig mit einer über gewinn steuer
sein denn für manche unternehmen macht
es wichtig seien jetzt höhere gewinne zu
machen nach jahren der pandemie bei
denen manche unternehmen hohe verluste
gemacht haben deshalb ein übergewicht
steuer sollte sehr fokussiert sein
sollte sich wirklich auf den bereich der
energie konzentrieren vor allem von
fossilen energieträgern noch ist die
über gewinn steuer nicht auf dem weg die
eu kommission hat sich dafür
ausgesprochen womöglich befasst sich
bald der bundestag damit
der tank rabatt hat die spritpreise in
den bundesländern unterschiedlich stark
sinken lassen das zeigt eine auswertung
vom institut der deutschen wirtschaft wo
hat der rabatt den stärksten effekt und
in welchem bundesland lässt es sich
besonders günstig tanken zahlen dazu
finden sie in unserer zdf heute
das pfingstwochenende gilt als erster
härtetest für die bahn seit dem start
des neuen euro tickets in weiten teilen
deutschlands gab es großes gedränge vor
allem in größeren städten zum beispiel
wie in berlin wer von dort an die ostsee
fahren wollte musste lange am gleis
warten um mit verspätungen rechnen
radtouren waren oft nicht möglich wegen
der hohen auslastung konnten fahrräder
in vielen bahn nicht mitgenommen werden
organspenden retten leben es gibt aber
zu weniger gesundheitsminister
lauterbach plant deshalb einen neuen
anlauf im bundestag für die
widerspruchsregelung das heißt wer nicht
ausdrücklich widerspricht wäre dann
spender ein blick auf die zahlen von
januar bis april 2022 gab es insgesamt
239 organspende rinnen und organspender
das sind 26 prozent weniger als im
vorjahreszeitraum
eine wirklich dramatische entwicklung
denn knapp 9000 menschen warten auf eine
lebensrettende
planta zion zum tag der organspende ein
bericht von trainer gerd
eine chronische sehr schwere
lungenerkrankung über zehn jahre
brauchte veronika wilhelm ein
sauerstoffgerät rund um die uhr 24
stunden am tag mittlerweile hat sie eine
spenderlunge erhalten ohne die
unterstützung von ihrem mann hätte sie
die zeit davor das ständige warten nicht
überstanden sagt sich
bringt wie kommt man sich
nicht wertlos will ich jetzt nicht sagen
aber man kriegt einfach nichts mehr auf
die reihe gar nichts und dann denkt man
schon bedingt wofür bist du überhaupt
noch da wenn du sowieso nichts mehr
machen kannst während der
lungentransplantation versagten ihre
nieren veronika wilhelm wurde
dialysepflichtig dreimal in der woche
musste sie zur blutwäsche wieder kam sie
auf die warteliste für ein spenderorgan
sie hatte glück musste darauf nur ein
paar monate warten im april bekam sie
eine neue niere für viele aber sieht die
realität anders aus die
organspendebereitschaft in deutschland
ist niedrig und mit corona ist die zahl
der tatsächlichen organspender noch
weiter gesunken die wartezeit offen ihre
ist momentan acht bis zehn jahre und
wenn man sich das überlegt die patienten
die an der dialyse sind die also
natürlich dadurch auch immer mehr
krankheiten bekommen für die ist das
sehr schwer
gartenarbeit ohne atemnot veronika
wilhelm geht es gut spaß schon bis sie
auf ja aber angst
das schlimme geschehen damit kann nur
noch besser werden ein alltag ohne
lebensnotwendige maschinen viele jahre
war das für sie unvorstellbar jetzt ist
es neue normalität
jetzt einblick in die landwirtschaft
da es ja derzeit die spargel und
erdbeerernte in vollem gange das problem
ist aber beides wird nicht sonderlich
stark nachgefragt und wer doch spargel
und erdbeeren kaufen möchte der greift
immer häufiger zu ware aus dem ausland
die ist nämlich deutlich günstiger
manila hat sich mit dem thema
beschäftigt
schöne dicke stangen klasse eins dieser
spargel wird nicht mehr geerntet so eine
situation gab es noch nie auf dem hof
von spargel an bauer jörg heuer bei
hannover
das ist ein bisschen enttäuschende
anblick diese dieses feld hätte vor zwei
wochen in den ertrag genommen werden
können da wir aber zu dem zeitpunkt
nicht den absatz haben gehabt haben
haben das einfach wachsen lassen spargel
der jetzt durch wächst so geht es vielen
spargelbauern in deutschland die
nachfrage ist in dieser saison deutlich
gesunken nach dem edelgemüse also der
hauptauslöser punkt ist glaube ich der
ukraine krieg dadurch ist eine
verunsicherung beim kunden eingetreten
erspart sich dass der deutsche staat
sich halt das vom mund ab und deshalb
ist die nachfrage nach spargel erdbeeren
aber insgesamt obst und gemüse
gesungen besonders schmerzhaft für
heimische produzenten ist die
europäische billig konkurrenz aus dem
ausland deren spargel und erdbeeren in
deutschen supermärkten angeboten wird
spargelanbauer hierzulande können da
nicht mehr mithalten der preisdruck
führt schon seit jahren dazu dass die
anbauflächen reduziert werden bei
erdbeeren zum beispiel sind wir seit
fünf jahren stark rückläufig in den
anbauflächen und beim spargel auch seit
drei jahren und unsere betriebe werden
auch immer weniger
jetzt haben spargelbauer die hoffnung
dass der absatz ein wenig steigt
traditionell wird zu pfingsten mehr
spargel gegessen
queen elizabeth die zweite ist seit 70
jahren britischer könige 70 jahre das
ist eine lange zeit entsprechend
ausgiebig wird schon seit drei tagen
gefeiert rund um den buckingham palast
haben sich heute tausende von royalen
fans versammelt am abend gibt es hier
ein großes pop konzert mit stars wie liz
und duran duran
aber wohl ohne die queen die 9 96
jährige hatte auch schon auf den besuch
des traditionellen pferderennen simpson
verzichtet aus gesundheitlichen gründen
und jetzt kommt ihr zu einem richtigen
klassiker fußball katja so sieht's aus
heute abend spielt italien gegen
deutschland in der nations league und
nicht nur der bundestrainer hansi flick
hofft dass seine positive serie
weitergeht denn in seinen bisherigen
neun spielen als chefcoach ist die
nationalelf unbesiegt es ist die erste
etappe auf der sommertour mit vier
länderspielen auf die reisegruppe wartet
eine anspruchsvolle aufgabe vor rund
22.000 fans im stadion in bologna der
start in die nations league zeigen wie
gut das fliegt ihm wirklich ist ich
finde das ja
auch besser jetzt so nations league zu
spielen eben spiele wo es dann auch ja
doch um was geht es wenn man jetzt
wirklich nur ein testspiel und
freundschaftsspiele hätte danach sieht
man dann schon ein stück weit besser wo
wir stehen der abgestürzte europameister
befindet sich im umbruch trainer mancini
setzt auf junge spieler baut eine neue
mannschaft auf italien will den
abwärtstrend stoppen das dfb team den
aufwärtstrend bestätigen
die nationalelf muss also am abend
leistung bringen die u21 hat das gestern
schon getan und das ticket für die em im
kommenden jahr gelöst in osnabrück
gewann das team von antonio di salvo 4 0
gegen ungarn der schönste treffer des
abends war auch gleich der erste das 1 0
durch sturmtalent josefa rokoko
in die bundesliga daniel farke wird
neuer trainer bei borussia
mönchengladbach und damit nachfolger von
adi hütter der 45 jährige war zuletzt
trainer beim russischen verein fk
krasnodar und zum tennis da hat die
politiker sonntag zum zweiten mal in
ihrer karriere die french open gewonnen
klar und deutlich mit 6 1 und 6 3 gegen
die us amerikanerin coco gov
freude pur nach dem finalsieg tigers
biotech gewinnt souverän das endspiel
der french open ihre gegnerin coco golf
hat zu keiner zeit ihre nervosität
ausblenden einfache fehler führen zum
schnellen ende des ersten satzes der nur
33 minuten dauert im zweiten durchgang
kommt die us-amerikanerin zwar besser
ins spiel kohl sogar ein break doch sie
am tag sorgt für ein schnelles ende nach
68 minuten 6 2 1 6 2
36 35 sieg nacheinander
derweil hört man von deutschlands tennis
profi nummer eins alexander zverev dass
er sich wohl mehrere bänder gestern im
halbfinale gerissen hat gegen rafael
nadal und mehrere wochen ausfällt aber
klingt doch sehr schmerzt danke katja
schon heute nach ziehen von südwesten
gewitter auf und morgen breiten sich
ziehen und wetter über fasten ganz
deutschland aus die einzelheiten hat
gleich katja horne war für sie das heute
journal können sie um 23.15 sehen wie
christian sievers schönen sonntagabend
noch
[Musik]
guten abend ein gewittertief komplex von
frankreich wird morgen wohl einige
pfingst unternehmungen verhageln davor
wird es schwül warm dahinter kühler die
gewitter kommen schon heute nacht im
südwesten an im norden ist es dagegen
klar da sinken die temperaturen zum teil
bis 6 grad im südwesten bleibt es
deutlich milder dampf ich bei 8 10 bis
14 grad und morgen erwarten uns meist
werte zwischen 26 und 29 grad an den
küsten und im westen ist bei 20 bis 25
grad schon angenehmer morgen vormittag
sehen sie hier in ostbayern noch kurz
die sonne und den ganzen tag über
freundlich bleibt es wohl nordöstlich
der elbe dann wälzen sich diese gewitter
heran und das sind richtige unwetter
besonders zwischen dem bodensee und
ostbayern erwarten wir hagelkörner mit
drei zentimeter korngröße regenmengen
von über 35 liter pro quadratmeter in
kurzer zeit und orkanböen bis 120
kilometer pro stunde auch sonst gibt es
häufig unwetter die fallen aber nicht
ganz so heftig aus mit den unwettern ist
es dann bringst montag und dienstag
vorbei wechselhaft geht es zur
wochenmitte weiter frohe kingston